well poetry is humanities answer to
immortality I mean if you had to talk
about what poetry is about what all
poetry is about it's about time and
mortality that we live these finite
existences through the world because the
world every year renews itself in spring
and we see this kind of cyclical aspect
of natural life and yet our own lives
are linear in finite and it makes in a
sense in something enormously precious
if we were gods if we were eternal we
would not need poetry we would not need
the arts we would have existence
unchallenged unlimited but because we're
mortal because we face death we have to
in a sense constantly stop and
understand our lives in different ways
you